let's go to yet another accuser of
impropriety and inappropriate behavior
by Donald Trump Republican presidential
nominee Donald Trump was accused last
week of making sexual comments to Marlee
Matlin now who is Marlee Matlin she is
the oscar-winning actress who once
competed in Donald Trump's program
Celebrity Apprentice she is known to
some people I know for her appearance on
a Seinfeld episode as well now it has
been alleged that Donald Trump also
seemingly had a Kabat of insulting
mimicking and demeaning Marlee Matlin as
quote [ __ ] because she was deaf and
she is deaf according to three longtime
staffers who worked on that particular
season of Celebrity Apprentice Trump
would reportedly regularly disrespect
Marlee Matlin and would even treat her
as if she was mentally disabled because
she is deaf sometimes the insults would
reportedly be behind her back sometimes
the insults would be right in front of
her and of course we know about these
really extensive non-disclosure
agreements that everybody involved with
anything that Trump does have to sign uh
all this the sources said I will talk
about this but only anonymously because
a fear of retribution of one source said
Trump would often equate that she was
mentally [ __ ] Trump would sometimes
you would see Trump scribbling notes
during The Apprentice and then someone
who was familiar with the notes would
say for example Trump would write down
Marlee is she [ __ ] of course Marlee
death not in any way uh mentally
handicapped or disabled then during
breaks Donald Trump would often still be
miked up he would be engaging in
chitchat maybe with Donald Trump jr. or
other people he would make fun of Marlee
Matlin's voice because she is deaf and
she speaks in a particular way every
indication Pat from everybody that's
been spoken to is that this is exactly
in line with what Donald Trump has said
that uh he he he does ray doesn't have
much tolerance for people who don't have
the right physical appearance who people
who don't act in the right way it's not
like it's super hard to believe because
Trump has a history of making fun of
disabled people remember while street
journalists uh Wall Street Journal
journalist so who-who Trump said I never
met the guy he actually met him twelve
times etcetera everything we're hearing
is not
only absolutely offensive but completely
in line with what we've learned about
Trump I think during this whole campaign
the most damning an offensive thing that
he's done was maybe break in front of
that reporter because everyone knows or
is related to someone with some special
needs of course and then of course
claiming he doesn't know the person he
did know the person will get to more
about Trump's denials about knowing
people a little bit later Omaha Steaks
sent me a great package of steaks and it
was fantastic as some of the audience
knows my girlfriend is pescetarian so I
invited over some of my meat eating
friends and we use my new grill that I
finally got now that it's almost fall
and everybody loved it it was terrific I
kind of rather grill in the fall than
summer just less oppressively hot and
the limited time family grill pack that
Omaha Steaks is offering for just $49.99
is a really great way to do it you will
get two filet mignons
to top sirloins for boneless pork chops
for chicken-fried steaks a 12 ounce
package of all beef meatballs for Omaha
steaks burgers for gourmet jumbo Franks
a 16 ounce package of Omaha Steakhouse
fries for caramel apple tartlets Omaha
Steaks seasoning and for additional
Omaha Steaks burgers and just for my
listeners Omaha Steaks is offering all
of this for only $49.99 this is a huge
savings go to Omaha Steaks dot-com enter
my code Pakman in the search bar and add
the family grill pack to your cart do
not miss this deal visit Omaha Steaks
dot-com and enter my code Pakman in the
search bar to get over 30 gourmet items
for $49.99